et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
cédric au bonjour je vous remercie
beaucoup d'être avec nous au secrétaire
d'état chargé de la transition numérique
et des communications électroniques
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse du quotidien régional bonjour
pascal jalabert du groupe ebra les
journaux régionaux de l'est de la france
on commence avec l'actualité du jour et
cette réunion à béthune pour tenter de
sauver l'usiné bridgestone et ses 8 163
salariés réunion entre deux ministres
les élus les syndicats
est ce que l'état peut sauver le site et
les emplois il faut l'espérer je
comprends que en tout cas à force de
négociations notamment daniel spagnou
nash et nous avons gagné un délais de
négociation il faut espérer que ce délai
permettre de rebattre les cartes
maintenant on va voir ce que demande
l'entreprise et je pense qu'il faut
espérer tout faire pour sauver ses
emplois et l'état peut faire quelque
chose dont l'état est impuissant face à
la décision de rio sont l'état ne peut
pas tout mais l'état beaucoup de levier
dans les mains des leviers financiers
d'élever d'investissement avec le plan
de relance
un des leviers sur la relocalisation
puisqu'on a débloqué un milliard d'euros
pour aider les entreprises à se
relocaliser je pense qu'on peut faire
des choses
maintenant ça au dépend aussi de la
volonté de l'entreprise parce qu'on ne
pourra rien s'il ya une volonté
déterminée de l'autre prise de fermer
c'est cette négociation qu'on doit avoir
à la fois en agitant la carotte et le
bâton
allez on va parler de la crise sanitaire
et sata logement du protocole dans les
écoles oui alors ce protocole dans les
écoles poser souci
est-ce que c'est pas contradictoires un
finalement avec la volonté de ralentir
le virus je pense qu'il ya toujours une
ligne de crête à trouver entre continuer
à vivre à vivre avec le virus et
ralentir la progression est en général
quand on prend un certain nombre de
décisions session sur des bases
scientifiques là je crois qu'il ya un
rapport scientifique qui dit qu' au
niveau des écoles la propagation du
virus est limité et je pense que c'est
absolument indispensable de pouvoir
continuer à mettre les enfants à l'école
moi j'ai deux enfants qui sont en bas
âge et à l'école et c'est sûr que je
comprends la détresse des parents
notamment dans un moment où c'est moins
bien acceptée par les employeurs
de rester à la maison pour garder son
enfant de ne pas pouvoir mettre les
enfants à l'école donc à partir du
moment où les scientifiques disent il ya
des risques limités
je pense qu'il est justifié d'alléger le
protocole est par ailleurs c'est vrai
que pour des enfants qui peuvent avoir 6
7 8 ans ou même plus jeunes le fait de
voir systématiquement des gens avec un
masque ça peut aussi avoir des
conséquences psychologiques donc je
pense qu'il faut mettre en balance les
conséquences de long terme
la vie quotidienne et puis la nécessité
impérative vous accuse toujours de
vouloir faire à tout prix redémarrer
l'économie
ça redémarre pas qu'est ce qui se passe
mais je pense que c'est un problème
mondial on voit ce qui se passe en
grande-bretagne et tous les
gouvernements sont tenaillés entre les
problèmes liés aux décisions prises à
cause du courant d'un virus la fermeture
anticipée des bars des restaurants les
éventuelles décisions voit que la
grande-bretagne évoque un confinement
et puis la nécessité de protéger ses
citoyens donc on est dedans c'est juste
équilibre on doit parfois l'adapter je
crois qu'aujourd'hui il ya des annonces
sur lyon et marseille non lieu ou non li
ion li ion li ion notamment n'ya pas
après nice apprennent en cela par
exemple à lyon après nice et marseille
effectivement qui sont des zones où où
le virus se propage on a écarté le fait
de recombiner totalement donc maintenant
il faut adapter à la situation locale
mais c'est toujours compliqué alors
parmi les outils mis en place par le
gouvernement pour lutter contre ce qu
vide 19 il y avait cette application il
ya cette application stop qu'ovide sauf
qu'on va le voir sur cette infographie
stop coville il n'est pas beaucoup
téléchargées en france très peu de
français l'ont comparé à d'autres pays
européens est ce que clairement vous
dites stop cowitz est un échec
alors je pense que vos chiffres sont
faux par bach pourquoi c'est vrai qu'il
ya deux pays en allemagne en parlant en
europe où ça se passe bien mais l'italie
sont pas 17 % sage tout cas ils
s'adressent ils sont gagnants soit entre
4 et 5 millions et français en fait pas
tant que ça entre 4 et 5 millions mais
même après 4,5 millions c'est
insuffisant pour être
très efficace donc il faut le
reconnaître ce stock au top comme une
marche bien fonctionnellement il a
insuffisamment été téléchargée pourrait
être utile mais pourquoi je pense qu'il
ya vraiment beaucoup de causes qui
peuvent être à la fois des causses
culturelle des causes liées aux débats
qui ont eu lieu sur l'application
je pense que c'est le moment où on a
besoin que les français le télécharge
notamment parce que il faut couvrir
certains cas transmission dans les bars
dans les grandes réunions qu'on ne sait
pas à couvrir
sinon et donc c'est un outil en plus
c'est pas la panacée c'est pas un outil
magique mais ça outils en plus qui peut
aider à ralentir l'épidémie est donc je
souhaite que les français de télécharge
mais les convaincre ces français de
télécharger qu'est ce que vous leur
dites ce matin pour qu'ils aient envie
de télécharger stop il ya une discussion
en cours au sein du gouvernement et
notamment avec olivier ferrand qui s'est
engagé très clairement sur le sujet
depuis le début je pense qu'il ya une
question de pédagogie
sinon on se rend compte quand on regarde
un peu les études qui s'en fait c'est
que in fine et les français n'ont pas
totalement perçu la valeur ajoutée de
cette application est donc je pense que
c'est à nous de la ré expliquer
peut-être delà de la focaliser sur un
certain nombre de cas d'usagé citer le
cas des restaurants le cas des réunions
le cad quand vous vous réunissez en
famille ou quand vous réunissez dehors
ces moments où on fait alors en famille
ce n'est pas le cas mais pour le reste
on ne connaît pas vraiment les gens qui
sont autour de nous et où ça peut être
utile d'être alerté 6
si on a été en contact avec des gens qui
ensuite sont testés positifs ça veut
dire quoi vous allez retravailler la
communication vous allez relancer une
campagne de communication sur stop
loving mais comme vous le savez il ya
une discussion qui doit avoir lieu
mercredi matin un conseil de défense
dont confère à ce moment là en tout cas
vous allez travailler là dessus oui
c'est sur la table mais est-ce que du
coup n'est pas répondu à ma première
question est ce que maintenant
aujourd'hui en tout cas avant le conseil
de défense vous reconnaissez que c'est
un échec ça ne marche pas c'est si la
question c'est est ce qu'on ne devait ne
pas le faire non je ne suis pas d'accord
est-ce que le constat c'est c'est un
échec pour le moment le conseil que
c'est un jeu suffisamment télécharger
mais je regardais un nouveau un de vos
collègues qui disait c'est comme si on
avait mis la ceinture de sécurité les
gens ne m'étais pas fait ce qu'il
fallait pas la faire
je ne pense pas est ce qu'il faut faire
plus de pédagogie qui ont su persuader
il ya un sénateur
l air de l'ange je sais pas si vous avez
vu qu'ils proposeront stop qu'ovide
obligatoire est ce que pour vous c'est
une solution non mais je pense qu'on ne
résout pas les problèmes en rendant les
choses obligatoires d'abord je pense que
nous n'aurions pas le droit légalement
nous sommes engagés auprès de la cnas
que ne soit pas le cas
nous avons toujours dit que ce serait
sur une base volontaire et je pense que
ça fait partie du contrat qu'on a avec
les français et que rien ne serait pire
que de le rendre obligatoire
donc il faut continuer à faire de la
pédagogie ça peut être utile ça peut
éviter des contaminations mais je ne ne
sera jamais obligatoire
avez vous de terminer avec le co vite on
a vu pendant la crise du coc vide sur
l'enseignement à distance notamment que
des jeunes français n'avaient pas les
enseignements parce qu'ils n'avaient pas
le numérique chez eux parce que leurs
familles ne maîtrisez pas avez-vous pris
des mesures pour éviter que ça se
renouvelle
alors il ya plusieurs éléments liés aux
difficultés d'éducation pendant locaux
vides notamment liés à l'équipement mais
si on parle plus généralement de la
fracture numérique qui a été extrêmement
prégnante pendant le comice cet état de
fait directement liée à la non ce que
nous avons fait pendant le plan de
relance qui est de généraliser la fibre
d'ici 2025 d'accélérer et même de créer
un service universel sur le sujet on
s'est rendu compte que pendant locaux
vides il y avait deux réalités ce qui
était que ceux qui avaient la connexion
que ce soit le mobile ou la fibre est ce
qu'ils n'avaient pas et donc on doit
encore accélérer on est déjà les
champions du monde du déploiement de la
fibre en europe et du déploiement des
pylônes pour vous donner une idée la
moitié de la fibre qui est déployé en
europe est déployé en france
donc la france et la moitié des diplômes
en europe il appert aucun pays dans le
monde qui déploie aussi vite que nous
mais on doit encore aller plus vite
parce que on se rend compte que c'est
devenu quasiment aussi indispensable que
l'eau l'électricité sans justement on
est les champions d'europe de la fibre
par contre on est à zéro pointé sur la
5g puisqu'on est le seul pays parmi
nouveau inquiets pas mis de deux pilotes
alors sans aller jusqu'à les pays bas
qui ont franchi le cap des 1000 au
pilote qu'est ce qui se passe en france
avec sept sages et pourquoi fait-elle
peur je pense que il ya plusieurs
éléments d'abord il faut vraiment
rappeler je viens de le faire que ces
packages ou 5 g aujourd'hui en france on
déploie il ya 60 à 70 pylônes chaque
semaine qui s'allument dans les zones
blanches
donc on accélère extrêmement vite et
d'ailleurs la 5g elle viendra sur les
pylônes
j'ai ça il faut le dire donc y aura pas
de nouveaux pylônes il y aura très peu
de nouveaux pylônes en tout cas dans
l'extrême majorité on mettra les
antennes 5g sur des pylônes 4g donc ya
pas de dichotomie ou de contradiction
entre déployer de la 4g c'est une folle
vient pas c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui s'interrogent avec qu'ils
disent mais pourquoi on travaille sur la
5g alors que nous on n'a pas la 3g on
n'a pas la cad j'ai donc vous dites à
ces gens qui sont encore dans des zones
blanches
on travaillera quand même sur les zones
blanches et la priorité n'est pas donné
à la 5g au détriment des hommes blancs
non seulement on travaille sur les zones
blanches mais je vais vous donner juste
un chiffre avant 2018 les gouvernements
successifs ont à lomé allumé six ans
pylônes en 15 ans dans les zones
blanches nous dans les deux années qui
viennent là on en a lu 2000 donc on fait
en deux ans trois fois plus que ce qui a
été fait en quinze ans au total on en a
mais rare entre dix et douze mille dans
les zones blanches
donc il va y avoir je sais que c'est
pour les gens c'est toujours trop lent
trop compliqué mais dans les deux ans
qui viennent et même dans les années qui
viennent il va y avoir un changement
drastique dans les zones blanches
moi j'étais toutes les semaines je vais
inaugurer des pylônes j'étais dans le
maine et loire dans l'yonne et la
semaine dernière dans la loire et je
vais cette année cette semaine à lens et
la semaine d'après à toulouse donc en en
allume partout dans les zones blanches
et on a un effort qu'on ne connaît dans
aucun autre pays par dessus ça on estime
qu'il faut déployer la 5g parce que la
5g s'est dé nouveau service pour les
consommateurs mais aussi indispensable
pour l'industrie et que ce serait
complètement antinomique
ça n'aurait aucun sens de dire qu'on
veut réindustrialiser la france si on
n'a pas la 5g
à l'heure où tout le monde ne déploie
vous citez vous citiez tout à l'heure
les pays-bas faut juste avoir en tête
que les chinois qui sont 100 millions à
avoir un abonnement 5 g que les coréens
ils sont 7 millions et que les
américains
il estime que sans la 5g il ne rien dû
se réaliseront pas donc on est dans
cette tension là après pardon pour
répondre à votre question il ya des
questions qui se posent et qui sont
normales notamment d'une partie de la
pas de lassitude d'une partie des
citoyens sur les questions sanitaires ou
les questions environnementales sur les
questions sanitaires on a eu un rapport
qui a été rendu la semaine dernière qui
fait le point sur les connaissances
académiques et qui fait le point sur les
décisions de toutes les autorités de
santé des pays y en a 21 qui ont déployé
de la 5g aujourd'hui il n'a jamais été
avérée il ya eu 28 l'étude depuis 1950
dans le monde 28000 il n'a jamais été
avéré qu'il y avait des effets
sanitaires
les ondes téléphoniques en dessous des
seuils minimums d'exposition et je
rappelle que en termes de protection par
rapport au seuil d'exposition notamment
grâce à des lois qui ont été votées par
les écologistes
je pense à la loi abeilles aujourd'hui
en france on a un des cadres les plus
dures du monde en moyenne quand vous
êtes dans la rue vous êtes exposés à une
puissance dombes qui est 100 fois
inférieure aux valeurs limites et on
fait 4000 contrôles par an partout en
france
donc moi je suis tout à fait disposé à
discuter notamment avec les maires
notamment avec les élus locaux
d'augmenter ce nombre de contrôles pour
être certain qu'on dépasse jamais mais
vous dites ce matin aux français qui
nous regardent la 5g c'est pas dangereux
pour votre santé dans la 5g n'est pas
dangereuse pour la santé
ça c'est certain et par ailleurs pardon
de cours pour suivre un petit peu mais
il ya cette question environnementale
dont on sent qu'elle qu'elle met à juste
titre est importante pour les gens il
faut avoir en tête qu'il ya deux choses
d'abord les réseaux 4g vont saturer dans
les grandes villes d'ici un ou deux ans
un peu partout en france et donc là on
va avoir un choix soit laissée saturé on
parlait du confinement je pense pas que
ce soit la bonne solution soit remettre
des antennes 4g soit mettre des antennes
5 g qui consomme 10 à 20 pour -
chrysanthèmes kg donc l'écologie du
quotidien pour les mères y compris pour
les mères de tours de marseille de
bordeaux et de grenoble ça va être de
faire ce choix là il va falloir qu'ils
expliquent alors citoyens s'ils
préfèrent laisser saturés ou mettent des
antennes qui consomment beaucoup m d un
thème qui consomme moins ça va ça va
être très est ce que vous allez faire
une inde et impute des études d'impact
climatique environnementale sur le
déploiement de 7,5 g je crois que c'est
pas le cas jusqu'à maintenant
alors ce à quoi on travaille on a lancé
un rapport entre une mission commune
entre l'arcep et l'ademe qui sont donc
deux institutions indépendantes
c'est à travailler sur la réduction de
la consommation d antenne parce que même
si on estime que c'est bon pour
l'environnement
on est d'accord pour dire il faut qu'ils
aient un peu plus de sobriété
énergétique faut qu'on travaille sur la
réutilisation des téléphones portables
on travaille sur la réduction de
l'empreinte énergétique et donc ceux ci
il ya une feuille de route qui est en
train de travailler sur ce sujet et plus
généralement sur le sujet numérique et
environnement parce que là où on est
d'accord avec les maires écologistes et
un certain nombre d'élus c'est que où il
faut réduire l'empreinte énergétique du
numérique mais ça ne veut pas dire
d'être dans le toujours moins nous ce
qu'on veut faire c'est d'être dans le
toujours mieux quelque part et la 5g ça
participe de ce mieux parce que pour la
même bande passante on consomme moins
vous dites ce matin aux élus notamment
et aux parlementaires qui demandent
certains parlementaires qui demandent un
débat voire qui demande un moratoire
il n'y aura pas de moratoire on
développera la sainte j'écoute coq outre
d'un le moratoire c'est non on l'a déjà
dit pardon de le dire à ceux qui
découvrent la 5g mais la première fois
que par exemple monsieur eric piolle a
reçu un courrier sur l'a5 geste en mars
2010 8ème et revenir mahjoubi le bord de
mer de g mounir mahjoubi mon
prédécesseur il a présenté la feuille de
route nationale sur la 5g en décembre
2018 donc tous ceux qui nous disent on
découvre la 5g c'est soit qu'ils sont
malhonnêtes soit qu'ils sont
incompétents pardon de le dire aussi
directement donc et par ailleurs l'arcep
l'autorité de régulation des télécoms
elle consulte depuis longtemps à partir
du moment où on considère que les sujets
sanitaires y en a pas que les sujets
environnementaux la 5g est plutôt
bénéfique pour l'environnement
nous on assume de déployer la 5g
maintenant parce qu'il ya la plupart des
pays qui sont partis depuis deux ans et
que on est dans une crise où on a besoin
de la 5g pour l'industrie pour les
services et y compris pour le
consommateur pour lui apporte été une
meilleure qualité parce que moi je n'ai
pas de mépris pour dire qu'on va
améliorer la vie du consommateur
on veut le faire par ailleurs dans la
ruralité parce que l'idée cas d'usagé la
télémédecine l'agriculture qui ont
besoin de la 5g aussi pour progresser et
donc à partir de là on assume de ne pas
de ne pas attendre donc le moratoire
c'est non par contre on est d'accord et
moi je suis totalement près de 10 k 10
pour discuter avec les maires d'une
meilleure information c'est qu'ils se
plaignent souvent de cette question du
dossier d'information au maire quitte un
peu technique mais pour qu'ils sachent
quand une antenne va arriver chez eux
qu'on puisse systématiser un certain
nombre de simulations qui montre comment
les ondes vont se répandre sur la zone
et puis qu'on puisse augmenter le nombre
de contrôles si les mères qui
aujourd'hui craignent un peu la 5g ont
besoin qu'on les rassure si les citoyens
ont besoin qu'on les rassure en
augmentant le nombre de contrôles nombre
de contrôles ces panneaux qui dessine on
n'a pas le temps c'est une association
environnementale ou un maire qui dit moi
je voudrais qu'on fasse un contrôle là
parce que j'ai un doute mais aucun
problème donc d'accord pour des
discussions avec les maires mais pas
d'accord pour décaler votre calendrier
dès qu'elles n'ont pas le calendrier on
va passer au plan de relance
7 milliards pour le numérique on va le
voir lors qu'on espère on va le voir ces
7 milliards et
la répartition à quoi ils vont servir
ces 7 milliards pour le numérique quelle
est la priorité pour vous
alors il ya deux grandes priorités
23dans priorité d'abord continuer à
développer les entreprises du numérique
qui créent de l'emploi partout en france
aujourd'hui le numérique est le secteur
qui crée le plus d'emplois en france et
on sait que par ailleurs ce sont des
emplois d'avenir à tous les niveaux de
compétence la crise un écart n'a pas
ralenti le rythme des créations elle a
ralenti le rythme des créations mais
c'est encore un secteur qui crée de
l'emploi
dire que même dans cette période de
crise n'est pas de plans sociaux
numériques
il peut y avoir des entreprises qui a
des moments vont mal ça peut arriver
mais grosso modo le secteur crée de
l'emploi donc les gens qui doit partir
d'une entreprise trouve très très vite
un emploi dans d'autres entreprises
encore aujourd'hui j'étais la semaine
dernière à saint-etienne ce que me
disent les intruses numérique c'est
qu'ils ont encore du mal à recruter
donc on est dans un c'est la transition
numérique c'est à dire que l'autre
d'économies est en train de se
transformer et les entreprises du
numérique prennent le relais donc on a
mis de l'argent sur ces entreprises pour
qu'elles continuent à se développer à la
fois parce qu'elle crée de l'emploi
puisqu'elle elles sont importantes si on
veut faire en sorte demain d'avoir des
champions d'amérique vous et que vous
évoquez les très grandes entreprises du
numérique avec versant de l'est on voit
que la taille de nos entreprises
augmentent mais on veut aussi avoir été
champion ça c'est le premier élément
le deuxième élément c'est la question du
numérique du quotidien c'est que à
l'autre bout de la chaîne quelque part
on veut accompagner les gens notamment
pour lutter contre l'électronique mme et
pour apporter la connexion j'ai évoqué
la question de la film c'est très
important pour nous c'est à dire que si
on veut continuer à parler de numérique
de technologie de progrès je pense qu'il
faut que tout le monde se sente à bord
donc on doit connecter les gens et on
doit leur apprendre à se servir d'un
ordinateur parce qu'il ya aujourd'hui un
français sur trois 1 français sur 6 qui
ne sait pas se servir d'un ordinateur ou
qui a des difficultés avec le numérique
et justement on va parler de ça on va
parler de ce qu'on appelle un peu l'île
etc trop nisme c'est en quelque sorte
l'illettrisme numérique c'est comme vous
le dites les gens qui ne savent pas se
servir d'internet d'un ordinateur de
leurs tablettes le sénat à travailler
sur ce sujet a rendu un rapport
récemment il demande au gouvernement une
politique ambitieuse dans laquelle
l'inclusion numérique serait pour
proclamer priorité nationale est ce que
vous êtes prêt à aller jusque là
mais bien sûr alors j'ai été auditionnée
par la mission
du sénat qui a fait un travail
remarquable je trouve ça très bien que
le sénat puisse saisir de ce sujet qui
est vraiment un sujet très territorial
et du quotidien c'est vraiment le
numérique du quotidien
pour vous donner une idée là dans le
plan de relance on a décidé de dédier
250 millions d'euros a grosso modo
embaucher plus de médiateur numérique et
financé plus de lieux qui forment au
numérique
le précédent plan poussé mois qu'il
avait présenté il était de 15 millions
d'euros
donc entre les deux on a multiplié le
chiffre qu'on consacre à l'inclusion
numérique de parvint presque un peu
moins de 20 ans avec les sénateurs
disent que c'est pas suffisant c'est
notamment sur les 250 milliards
consacrés à la formation 250 millions
consacrés à la formation il demande 1
milliard alors j'ai entendu ce chiffre
du milliard là les 250 millions on va
devoir les déployer dans les deux ans
qui viennent
honnêtement parler à tous les
spécialistes du secteur ça va être
difficile de les déployer parce que
c'est une politique publique qui encore
un peu de structure et donc bien sûr
qu'il faudra aller plus loin bien sûr
qu'avec les 250 millions on est pas
quitte si je puis me permettre
mais là on va faire un saut quantique
pour reprendre une analogie numérique
sur le sujet c'est à dire que jamais un
gouvernement n'a fait autant d'efforts
et déjà envoyé plusieurs milliers de
formateurs
sur tout le territoire dans les bonnes
dans les banlieues avec les bons
équipements pour former des centaines de
milliers voire des millions de français
dans les deux ans qui viennent
ça va être une difficulté opération est
forte donc je suis d'accord pour le
milliard à terme mais d'abord faisons en
sorte que ces 250 millions ils soient
bien dépensés dans l'es2 en foot ils
allaient colbert rendre le numérique
comme les maths le français leur belle
histoire et j'ai eu une matière
obligatoire noté est enseignée par tous
alors vous savez que depuis la rentrée
2010 9 tous les lycéens de seconde font
une heure et demie numérique oui par
semaine et je compare avec des choses
qu'on apprend dès le court éléments
alors et par ailleurs il ya toute une
feuille de route du ministère de
l'éducation nationale sur la question du
numérique mais j'insiste sur cette
question de la seconde parce qu'il ya
aucun pays du monde qui le fait hier
pour tous ses étés lycéens de faire 1h30
de numérique et par ailleurs il ya toute
une feuille de transformation de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer a réuni les états généraux du
numérique éducatif en octobre je crois
et cette question elle est bien sûr au
coeur parce que à la fois il faut
apprendre à s'en servir mais surtout il
faut apprendre à comprendre
le numérique c'est pas que des outils
c'est de comprendre ce qui se passe avec
les données avec les réseaux sociaux
avec la question des écrans et donc on a
besoin non seulement d'apprendre aux
enfants à coder parce que c'est un peu
comme une troisième langue vivante si
j'ai fait un parallèle mais aussi de
leur apprendre à comprendre le monde
dans lequel il évolue
pour mieux être des pour être des futurs
citoyens complètement autonome
allez on va terminer par quelques
questions politiques pour finir cedrico
et on apprend à l'instant que pierre
person pierre person qu'est le numéro
deux du parti la république en marche la
déléguée générale adjointe quitte le
parti
c'est ce qu'il dit dans une interview au
monde ce matin parce que ce mouvement ne
permet ni de mener le rassemblement ni
de produire des idées neuves c'est ce
qu'il dit qu'est ce que vous en pensez
quelle est votre réaction à cette
démission du parti mais je pense qu'il
s'agit là d'une clarification bienvenus
pierre pour dire le moins n'était plus
très engagé dans le parti depuis assez
longtemps dont il était pourtant le
numéro 2 donc je ne vais pas ya cet
ancien de produire des 19 pardon mais
s'il avait dû le faire ça fait je pense
deux ans qu'il est numéro deux était
peut-être temps de s'en apercevoir
cette question des idées neuves c'est
une ancienne qui revient à chaque fois
quand un parti au pouvoir au pouvoir on
sait que c'est toujours très compliqué
donc là je pense qu'il s'agit plus d'un
sujet personnel que d'un sujet politique
continue à avancer je pense que la suite
le sujet est anecdotique algérien dit
pardon il ya quand même aucun sujet
personnel mais quand on regarde les
résultats électoraux les partiels hier
ont été loupé les municipales ont été
loupé les régionales s'annonce pas bien
comment ce parti petit prendre racine
dans le pays on va peut-être passer si
législatives partielles hier et aucun
candidat de la république en marche qui
n'accèdent au second tour et quand un
parti au gouvernement depuis trois ans
gagne une élection législative c'est
plutôt l'exception que la règle
j'étais je travaillais pour le parti
socialiste dont j'étais dans le
gouvernement socialiste précédent
on perdait quasi systématiquement toutes
les législatives partielles
donc il est assez normal l'usure du
pouvoir faisant son boulot qu'en général
le parti au pouvoir perde les
législatives
effectivement ce que je pensais qu'il
faut travailler sur les échéances qui
viennent et la question des régionales
il ya des questions
des sénatoriales qui sont vous allez
travailler sur la question d'un jeune
âge vous pourriez être candidat aux
régionales vous coûter pour l'instant ce
n'est pas d'actualité
c'est à dire que là je pense qu'il a
envie écoutez moi je n'ai jamais conçu
ma mon parcours dans une perspective et
élective eux
donc on verra ce qui se passe mais je
considère que l'engagement politique est
plutôt un engagement avec une profession
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on a lancé
en marche parce qu'après je retournerai
dans le secteur privé
après je ne l'écarté pas parce que je
pense que se frotter au terrain est
frotté à l'élection est une bonne chose
mais bon voilà je n'en fais pas l'alpha
et l'oméga de mon engagement et dernière
question vous le disais vous veniez du
ps il ya un mouvement qui a été lancée
ce week-end qui s'appelle territoire de
progrès qui a été lancée par la gauche
de la macro n'irait des gens qui comme
vous venez du parti socialiste vous
n'étiez pas au lancement de ce mouvement
pour quoi pour vous c'est pas une bonne
idée si c'est une bonne douche et j'ai
aucun problème avec eux territoire de
progrès je trouve ça très bien je vous
allez vas y adhérer non mais écoutez
bon moi je me sens toujours de gauche
vient de la gauche j'ai aucun problème
avec ce mouvement là je suis plutôt
partie de ceux qui ont créé en marché
qui ont voulu dépasser ce genre de
clivage est donc même si j'estime que le
territoire de progrès a vraiment son
utilité et sa justification
voilà moi je reste plutôt dans le corpus
ça fait retomber dans les clivages ce
genre de mouvement non parce que je
pense que c'est assez constructif si
vous voyez les prises de déclarations de
ladebat dont les prises de position les
déclarations de jean yves le drian
olivier du soft ils affirment leur
identité qui est une entité qui vient de
la gauche la social démocratie mais ils
sont dans une optique constructive donc
là aucun problème avec ça et merci
beaucoup merci c'est vrai quoi d'avoir
été avec nous sommes à 100 remercie
pascal janin vert et on passe ensuite au
club de territoire la mutuelle nationale
territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux
vous présente le club des territoires
angie acteurs engagés dans la transition
zéro carbone des régions vous présente
le club des territoires
[Musique]